now as the biden-harris self-inflicted
border catastrophe worsens by the hour
the democrats and their sycophantic
allies in the media are in full-on
damage control
just listen to msdnc's joy reid claiming
the crisis doesn't even exist
the roaming gnome is back at it again
governor christie gnome that is
it would appear that our inaugural
absolute worst is jealous of all the
attention our two record holders
republican governors greg abbott of
texas and
florida's ron desantis are getting so
she's sending south dakota's national
guard troops roaming
diploma deploying them to the southern
border of texas
joining fellow maga sycophant desantis
and the governors of iowa and nebraska
in sending
help to the border 50 national guard
troops are being deployed in response to
greg abbott's plea
for more border security for a
non-existent crisis
wow non-existent border encounters are
on pace for a two decade high cartels
are emboldened
human smugglers are operating in plain
sight drugs are pouring into our country
and authorities have over are completely
overwhelmed now remember
there's nothing compassionate about
illegal immigration and nothing
compassionate
about incentivizing this treacherous
journey from central america to the u.s
border
it's inhumane for the migrants and it's
a slap in the face to all of us here at
home
reckless immigration policy erodes trust
that our leaders will actually
faithfully execute the laws
and faithfully keep us safe and secure
what we're seeing at the border is a
full-fledged public safety risk
just listen to one mom in del rio texas
saying she's even scared to have her
kids play outside
i am constantly concerned right now with
my family's safety and that especially
of
our three daughters so when people say
well that's because you live on the
border
has it always been like this have you
always been concerned about your
your family safety i think our situation
is unique because we used to live on a
very large ranch west of del rio
but we moved to del rio seeking you know
the nice quiet safe yard that our girls
could grow up and play in
and within the last six months or so
activities here
it was peaceful for a while i was
actually enjoying having peace of mind
and allowing our kids to play outside
but
um they can't do that anymore
wow that's awful now don't forget when
donald trump left
office the border was as secure as it
ever had been
but then biden scrapped the highly
successful remain in mexico policy
he ended construction of the border wall
he reinstituted catch and release
and his open borders rhetoric sent a
message to migrants
that a new president meant no more
border enforcement
here now to break it all down former
acting ice director and
fox news contributor tom homan along
with fox and friends weekend co-host
rachel campos-duffy
and american conservative union chair
matt schlapp you know
let me start with you tom obviously it's
heartbreaking for all of us
to have seen such success from president
trump
to see our agencies working successfully
to secure people's lives and to make
everyone's lives better
south of the border and north and tom
now we just see it
set on fire uh essentially it seems
deliberately so what is your take on
where things stand now
oh the border's in complete chaos i've
been forced immigration law for almost
35 years
this is the worst i've ever seen it and
for the first lady that spoke said
there's not a crisis
i suggest that she go down to the rio
grande valley something kamala harris
didn't do
and spend one hour with the border
patrol i've been down there four times
when i spent an hour of border patrol i
watched him arrest 197
illegal migrants come across a river two
weeks ago i was in arizona i met with a
hundred
border sheriffs shares fall across
country plus
many border shares and and they will
tell you about the rise in fentanyl
uh overdoses the rise in fentanyl
seizures they'll tell you about the rise
in
high-speed car chases one border sheriff
alone
told me he already found 44 dead
migrants since
since jeremiah became president 44 dead
migrants in one county
so and plus what the lady says is insult
to the men and women of the border
who are dealing with this crisis every
day so i suggest you educate herself
because she's dead
wrong on this issue we have a crisis of
immense proportions
that i have never seen in my career and
yeah it's a great point sir
uh rachel this is not uh just
theoretical right we know there's
technical issues going on at the border
but you heard that mom you're a mom
people watching this are parents you
have people you love
this is about an event that directly
impacts the safety and security
of american families this is real life
what what were you thinking with that
with that mom
unable to really feel safe letting her
children even out of the house
yeah they actually caught an immigrant
coming up her driveway
who actually had a criminal sexual past
so this is a real thing she's petrified
and she said the border patrol is tied
up with
you know processing people and she was
lucky that someone in local law
enforcement
caught this man um and took him away but
remember
all of these people are going all over
the country
bob uh good a representative from from
texas
from virginia i'm sorry went down with
the republican study committee to look
at the border
now not only did they see that the
border was completely out of control as
tom holman has said but then he went to
the airport to go home and he found
all these illegal immigrants in the
airport in mcallen
um with manila folders and in these
manila folders they had
where they're going how to navigate the
the
airports and also they had what they
call
uh notice to appear paperwork from dhs
and those that paperwork says to be
determined
so they are not ever going to go to
court they're going they're being spread
out across the country
and the reason joy reid can say that
tammy is because
the biden administration isn't being
honest about this you know what i'd have
so much more respect for them if they
tell the truth say listen
we're opened up the border we want all
these people in we're
sending them to airports we're putting
them on buses and we're sending them
across the country yeah but they're
doing it and they're lying to us and you
know they're lying they're not doing it
yeah and they're lying about it matt
and great points rachel great stuff on
the weekend too with fox and friends in
the morning
they're lying about it because they know
americans
don't want it they know they they
and they of course have no regard for us
so they think we're just you know going
to believe it and swallow it whole
but the fact is matt you've got a
dynamic here where this
is once again forget about the quality
of life
whether it's in chicago or if it's at
the border or in los angeles
and doing this because they think it's
going to get them political power
is that going to unfold and will it be
successful
well look at where socialism is being
enforced
in our major cities people are fleeing
those cities and they're moving to
states like texas
and where what are the people doing who
are closest to the border
what are they doing they're actually
electing republicans
to to mayoral seats in historic wins
they're changing seats on school boards
because the crime associated with this
and the societal unrest associated with
this illegal crossing
is something that the people in texas
realize more
if you live on a border you realize what
the problems are the second thing is
it is about political power tammy h.r
one and all these legal reforms
take away all the voting security
there's going to be you know a million
new people
running around this country with they
will have no security on our voting
the modern democratic party is all about
not
following the rules and i think the
american people next november
are going to send them quite a message
well we have to because while you can
have
pockets rachel back to you very quickly
here
when you've got pockets of of cities
in areas whether they're blue or not
where there is such chaos and such a
lack of law and order
that is going to breed even more
violence every american matters
every city matters we don't care what
color those cities are
we are all invested in this country it
we can't have
a divided nation uh and yet that's also
what seems to be happening here where
you have a completely different quality
of life
uh is when it comes to the decisions
americans are making
and what cities uh we're fighting for is
is
what would you tell the average american
when we're dealing with waiting until
the midterms
what is it we need to do to keep our
communities in particularly uh
safe we need to keep talking about this
because again
the lies are so bad kamala harris is
claiming tammy that she's addressing the
root causes
but these policies are actually
empowering enriching
the cartels which is going to further
destabilize
the supposedly the root causes in these
countries
um this is actually so bad it is going
to get worse
as mexico and central america they're
having increased violence there
we're going to see that pouring up
across our border we're going to see
more people trying to flee
and we just have to stand up i think
you're absolutely right tammy we can't
wait until the midterms
this thing is getting out of control
there's a million people who will be
here
before the end of the year and we don't
know who they are
are you that's a great point tom in our
a minute we have uh
left here or so you know we've got to
and people we see families going to the
school board meetings we see families
going to the police department
we had a great decision in minneapolis
about
that they have to hire more police
officers uh so beyond like the larger
federal infrastructure dynamic what
would you with your experience
tell local families getting involved in
their community what should they
step up to do first do you think
they they need to start calling the
congressman and senators in home
responsibility because they work for
them not the other way around i want to
expand something that rachel just said
though rachel talked about
kamala harris talking about root causes
all come out here has to do is walk down
the hall into the oval office
and she'll find the real causes and one
other thing rachel talked about rachel's
spot on the airport
i was at the airport i was down on the
southern border with the president two
days ago
i was at mcallen airport i saw hundreds
of family units getting on those
airplanes
and not only that those get those
airline tickets are paid by the u.s
taxpayer companies
administration we get brand new iphone a
brand new iphone compliments of the
taxpayer
this is much worse than people realize
it is so you know
i think president trump made a good trip
down there he he actually got his shoes
dirty on the southern border thank you
talk to the men and women
and he actually talked about wishings to
fix the border unlike
anybody let me tell you thank you thank
you tom
not only is president trump he remains
inspirational
but so can individuals in their own
cities
is you know maybe you never thought you
were going to have to talk to the police
commissioner or to the mayor
that is your right you should do it and
you stepping up you've seen so many
parents becoming inspirations because of
viral videos
but it doesn't even need to be a video
it can be about your neighborhood
and your community so there's a great
deal that we can do uh
leading up to this midterm election
thank you all for joining me tonight hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it
anywhere else